Here are two numbers,
which I want to collect.
The first number is 327,
which means 3 hundreds,
I have 3 in the order of hundreds.
You see them right here.
You see these 3 hundreds,
each of these large squares contains
100 small squares, so 3 large ones
the square will be 3 hundred.
And then I have 2 tens.
2 tenths, 2 is in the order of the dozen,
so it's two decades right here.
And then I have 7 units.
7 is in the order of the units.
7 is in the order of the units
and you see these 7 units.
7 units, right here.
These are 3 hundred, 2 tenths
and 7 units, or 327.
Now I want to add 251,
or if you think otherwise,
I want to add 2 hundreds because 2
is in the order of hundreds, two hundred.
2 hundred,
1 hundred, 2 hundred.
50 is the same as 5 tens,
we see 5 in the order of the decimal.
5, let me write it in the same color.
Five tenths, right here.
1 tenth, 2 decades, 3 decades,
Four tenths, five tenths.
Finally, I have 1 in the order of units,
which simply means 1 unit.
You see it right here.
This is a unit.
1 unit.
Stop the video now
and check if you can collect these two numbers.
Now let's get together.
We have 7 units to them
we will add 1 unit. How many units will we get?
Okay, 7 units plus 1 unit
will be 8 units.
You see here 7 and then you have an eighth unit.
So 8 units, 7 plus 1 is 8.
Now let's look at the dozens.
I had 2 tens and I will add
another 5 decades, we collect them together
and we will have seven tenths.
2 tenths plus 5 tenths,
we will have seven tenths.
And finally,
if you have 3 hundreds and add 2 more,
how many hundreds will you have?
Well, you'll have five hundred.
You see these 5 groups of 100 right here.
Let's record 5 in the hundreds.
Therefore, 327 plus 251
is 578.
5 hundred, 7 tens
and 8 units.